colombia vive una nueva jornada de paro
nacional en lo que el comité nacional de
paro ha nombrado como la toma de
capitales mientras siguen las
negociaciones entre el propio comité
nacional de paro y el gobierno para
tratar de encontrar una salida al
conflicto que está rigiendo en colombia
desde el 28 de abril desde ese momento
las organizaciones denuncian que ha
habido más de 60 muertos más de 3.000
heridos y más de 100 desaparecidos unos
datos que sin embargo no han hecho que
el gobierno permita el acceso de la
corte interamericana de derechos humanos
pero si ha accedido una misión
internacional solidaria de verificación
argentina compuesta por 19 personas
puesto que uno cuando iban a ser 20 no
pudo pasar los controles migratorios la
violencia continua en el país
especialmente en el suroccidente y en la
jornada ayer en tuluá se vieron imágenes
del palacio de justicia ardiendo y
también un manifestante murió por herida
de bala que destaca que este miércoles
va a ser el aperitivo para la jornada
del viernes cuando se cumple un mes de
paro nacional en colombia